what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder today
we have
a spider-man no way home plot league
and honestly this does sound pretty dang
interesting
if the story ends up being somewhat like
this it's going to be a heck of a movie
and yes of course this does involve the
spider-verse now of course with all plot
lakes it's hard to tell
if this is legitimate or not some plot
leaks end up being true
and a lot of them end up not being true
this was posted anonymously online to
several pages like reddit and
4chan by somebody who has claimed to
have seen the storyboard for spiderman
no way home so like with all leaks take
this with a grain of salt but like i
said it does sound very
very exciting so let's get into it but
first i am giving away a captain america
falcon and the winter soldier shield
the giveaway ends at the end of this
month just subscribe to me and my other
channel cosmic culture i'll put the link
in the description down below that's how
you enter
so let's get started with this plot leak
it opens with spider-man being chased
through a broken
new york by some type of human
thunderstorm the electricity takes a
human shape and turns out to be jamie
foxx
he confronts spider-man stating that he
knows who he is and then he takes off
his mask and it is in fact
toby maguire electro is about to kill
spider-man but right before he does the
reality around them fractures and the
marvel opening credits begin
we then pick up right where we left off
in spider-man fire from home
tom holland's peter parker has just seen
the broadcast and is rushing
home desperately contacting aunt may and
happy he reaches his home and tells aunt
may they have to hide
they will become targets but it's too
late as the apartment complex is
attacked by michael mando's scorpion and
his men
in the fight the apartment explodes and
scorpion falls down
breaking his back and aunt may and peter
escape
they seek refuge at the new york sanctum
where they meet wong and dr strange
strange is busy analyzing several
fractures to their reality which started
after the blip but have been
increasing peter wants a spell to
reverse the uncovering of his identity
asking doctor strange what he can do but
doctor strange can do no spell but in
return he offers the asylum to mae for
her to hide and tells tom that he should
solve this like most people
in court then in another part of town
reality fractures and out comes a
confused looking
jamie foxx's electro the old avengers
tower now belongs to oscorp and they are
in fact
experimenting with fragments of both the
tesseract pym
particles and traces of the ether found
in london
phineas mason is working on this new
technology for an unseen
norman osborne and this leak describes
him as more of an elon musk
type of guy less overtly evil and more
charismatic
heck maybe elon musk is playing the
character himself i'm sure he'd love to
do that
multiple fractures in the reality are
reported
peter parker stands trial at court and
is unsuccessfully
defended by matt murdock aka daredevil
we have gotten some reports by some
major trade companies stating that matt
murdock
is going to be in spider-man no way home
however daredevil
is not it's simply going to be matt
murdock defending peter parker but it
does go on to say
due to the reality ripples peter has to
rush out of court and goes to a large
anomaly near the docks
when he gets there doctor strange is
trying to contain the anomaly but dr
strange is
pulled into the anomaly and peter is
unable to save him
peter then goes and contacts shield he
thought that mysterio lied about the
other dimensions but they believe
mysterio's scheme is a part of something
much
bigger he had a benefactor scorpion is
brought to michael keaton who of course
is playing adrian toombs aka vulture
and he runs a large repair shop vulture
owes
scorpion for their time shared in prison
and they offer up a lot of cash to take
care of scorpion
with the help of the tinkerer they use
one of the old iron man 2 suits that
they have collected to create an
exoskeleton for scorpion with a backed
base cannon and this would obviously
make him look more like scorpion from
the comics
a confused electro played by jimmy fox
is caught and brought into ozcorp and
he's greeted by norman osborne
this norman osborne seems relatively
nice with the disbanding of the avengers
norman wants to create his own
privatized team of superheroes as told
by his advisor
he's been getting messages from another
reality by none other than willem
dafoe's norman osborne and we have had
some reports from some media outlets
that willem dafoe could be reprising his
role as norman osborne in spider-man no
way home
and according to this leak he is and
this norman osborne is giving hints on
how to create a quantum portal to
connect both realities
this is one of the few surviving
realities and other realities are
desperate
to go to this reality the villains in
this movie all come from realities that
have been mostly destroyed this norman
osborne believes himself to be some kind
of tony stark and is building his own
group of superheroes
shelters are built for the reality
displaced people by the grc
we were introduced to the grc in the
falcon and the winter soldier grc
stands for the global repatriation
council and right now in the falcon and
the winter soldier we're kind of on the
fence on whether or not they're
truly good or not we're not sure if they
have ulterior motives yet
debates are held about this reality
taking in refugees from other realities
missing people duplicates and the like
are taken care of
among them is ben parker as one of the
few living relatives
aunt may is contacted and even peter
learns of his existence
both aunt may and peter go to see him
ben
is happy to see both of them as in his
reality they both had died
admittingly this would be a pretty cool
twist granted it wouldn't really be the
same
it's not the same ben parker he wouldn't
have experienced the same thing that
they all went through together in the
main reality but it still would be
pretty cool to see
learning from shield that the anomaly is
coming from the old avengers tower
our spider-man enters and confronts
norman osborne with the intention of
shutting the machine down
spider-man is still a wanted criminal
and norman tells him of a persistent
chance
he tells him the idea that some things
are simply inevitable
as if reality converges to certain
events like how most realities have
a spider-man he thought labeling this
spider-man a criminal
would be enough but he flushes the
spider-man down the drain into an
alternate reality
r tom holland peter parker wakes up in a
ravaged earth
not destroyed by thanos but by ego
star-lord's father
humanity has moved underground where dr
octavius is taking care of survivors
our peter parker is able to lead them
into another fracture of reality
they pass multiple different realities
and come across two
other spider-man our peter parker learns
about the feeling of seeking refuge and
has to find his way back home
following the trail that doctor strange
has left behind
back in the main mcu reality norman
osborne completes the quantum tuttle
bridging his reality to willem dafoe's
reality wollum defeats norman osborne
enters and then he promptly
kills the other norman osborn willem
dafoe wants to enjoy this reality and he
lavishes in its luxury
when traveling through different
realities our peter parker eventually
does find dr strange and he is able to
take them back to the main reality
the leak describes it as when they get
back to the reality it's a little
like back to the future too things have
been taken over by oscorp as time has
passed for several months
it has become highly militarized and
willem dafoe's norman osborne has
several protectors including
scorpion with his upgraded suit there's
the final battle which takes place over
several ravaged versions of new york
including one with dark elves
eventually our peter parker will have to
turn off the quantum tower
which will condemn all of the other
earths to their fate the reality
displaced people refract and go back to
their own realities
aunt may says goodbye to uncle ben once
again and peter parker says goodbye to
the other spider-man
they tell him that he's lucky and he
needs to take good care of his world
in the ending sequence the dead body of
r norman osborne is revived by dr
connor tinging his skin with a green hue
dr connor obviously being the lizard and
that's it for this plot leak and as i
mentioned it's very
very specific and unfortunately there's
no real way to tell if this is
legitimate or not
i think a movie like this would actually
be pretty cool to see
and although i doubt 100 of this will
happen i think some type of variation
of this would be really really cool but
let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below would you like to see
spider-man no way home play out like the
supposed plot leak let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you